- Alright.
Well, Rex, how did this start?
Because you didn't set out to
be popular on Twitter, right?
- No, you know, I played
basketball for a long time
and this just kind of...
A couple of years ago,
I was really frustrated with
the toxic social media
and kinda wanted off.
And I watched so much basketball.
I saw this video of a
dolphin swimming out,
a paddle boarder swimming in,
and a dolphin jumped up
and just hit the guy right in the chest
and a stupid basketball term.
- I've seen this.
- I said, "That's a
charge, a blocker charge."
(all laugh)
Well, I just twitted it out.
(woman claps)
And people thought it was kind of funny.
And then it grew from there.
So yeah, I
try to throw in some good feel-good stuff
from time to time to make people laugh.
- I mean, that dolphin
video never gets old.
(man laughs)
- It didn't charge.
- I know (laughs).
- Because his feet were
planted on the surfboard?
His feet were planted.
- See, see.
- He couldn't go the
other way 'cause dolphins
don't have feet.
- You know what you're doin'.
- Oh my God.
You know, sports ball.
- That's right.
- I know so much about sports.
People are always like-
- She does.
His feet are set.
Look, that's a charge.
(woman laughs)
Exactly Eliza called it.
- I played YMCA basketball.
So I know 'cause
I charged a lot.
- YMCA.
- I got a lot of red flags in lacrosse.
So I just know about
the aggressive behavior.
- Oh my gosh.
I love it, I love that.
(man laughs)
Well Rex, it's pretty cool to find a way
to make social media
help your mental state
instead of hurt it
because I'm gonna be honest with you.
I watched "The Social Dilemma."
I don't know if you ever
if you saw that
but it freaked me out.
And I think that, you know,
it is kind of daunting
the film in general,
but at the same time,
I love that you've used it
to help with mental health.
And how have you managed to do that?
- Like I mentioned at the beginning,
I played basketball forever.
In my last three years of playing,
I had seven orthopedic surgeries.
And right when I finished playing
I wasn't a drinker, or a smoker, nothing.
My whole career and a
doctor gave me Oxycontin.
And that set me on about a 15-year battle
with painkiller addiction.
I had three rehab stints.
And so finally about six years ago,
I went to rehab for the third time.
It took that time.
I've been off of painkillers
for about six years
and I know life is hard.
And you know...
Heck I lived in my car for a little while.
I made probably $40
million playing basketball.
And since then I've lived
in my car and lived on friend's couches.
So I can't...
I have the greatest debt
of gratitude to so many of my family
and friends who have supported
me through everything.
And I think with the Twitter, shoot,
I'm just happy to be able to bring
a smile to somebody's face
and happy that so many people
share their videos with me.
None of the content's mine.
They send it to me.
I put it out.
- Yeah.
Well you have made me smile a lot.
You're hilarious.